robotics is all about creating objective
and affordable Road assessments
communities governments municipalities
they're responsible for a portion of the
road network the first challenge that
they have though is trying to understand
what is the current status of the road
network today easiest way you could do
that as you go out in a car you drive
the entire road network and you take a
look at it there could be cracks there
could be potholes all of these surface
de-stresses that tell you something
about the status of that road network
what robotics does is we use a
smartphone and AI
and we can go out and we can take video
data in that same pattern that then gets
uploaded into our cloud systems where we
can process that data looking for the
same de-stresses except now it's a
machine that's doing it that's creating
an objective profile of your entire road
network and we can do it very quickly
and very affordably this gives
communities those same road managers
access to a quantitative data set that
they can then make decisions from do
they need more budget do they need less
budget where should they put those
resources should it be on that road or
that road robotics is sort of a small
example of a greater trend of using
artificial intelligence to replace
menial work you can do it systematically
and by that you can increase
transparency in equity the whole idea
started with me getting the small grant
at CMU as a researcher and so I
developed my idea there developed the
algorithm and now to see that it
actually is used in a company and gets
recognition that's really that's really
great because it's not just that the
algorithms worked but it's actually
real-world applications
you